Hawes is located in a remote part of
northern England the Yorkshire Dales
but this village is anything but sleepy
that's a large part due to councillor
John Lackey when the local post office
gas station library and bus service were
to be shut down he helped turn them into
community run operations
he plans to combat the effects of Briggs
at the same way
[Music]
you know we've managed to be their
self-reliant capital as they called us
elsewhere and we'll hang on to as many
services as we can for example the
community run gas station on this day
they're drawing visitors to [ __ ] with
low gasoline prices and who sets these
prices counselor John Blackie of course
he's a whirlwind he's a dynamo I think
he's ever I've lived in the area for 15
16 years now and really anything good
that's been done has come out of John
and his efforts so the almost 70 year
old advocates for affordable housing is
honorary chairman of the bus company
executive chair of the gas station and
supposed master at hospice office he's
also happy to provide info on the bus
schedule
in house it's still possible to borrow
library books or cash a check that used
to be a given throughout the Yorkshire
region until budget cuts led to the loss
of many services Blacky fierce brexit
will only make things worse we don't
have a grand master plan we deal with
issues as they arise but we deal with
them very quickly and if there's a
community solution there won't always be
but if there is we will find it and we
will implement it our just like they did
in the early 1990s when the cheese dairy
was slated to shut down Blacky helps
saved the Wensleydale Creamery together
with David Hartley who is now its
managing director the employees simply
took over the business and today the
creamery employs over 200 people and
exports cheese around the globe
he's been a champion of employment in
the area and a lot of the Dells yes we
rely on tourism we rely on agriculture
but a lot of it is about employment a
proper employment for the local people
still young families are leaving Harz
maintaining the villagers infrastructure
is becoming increasingly difficult and
it's just been announced that the only
bank branch were closed for good
you'll be used in the bank every day
wouldn't you I thought they might carry
on a bit longer yeah the last thing you
want the shops and premises to be empty
because when shops and premises are
empty people look at the place it starts
looked tired and dowdy and not thriving
and therefore people don't come but
we'll carry on in [ __ ] and we'll give
our example to other communities because
if we can do it they can do it not
taking no for an answer I can assure you
the little white bus is an example of
just how contagious jumped like his
enthusiasm can be he's recruited 60
volunteer drivers to show for tourists
and residents who can no longer drive
themselves they go on outings for
instance to enjoy tea sandwiches in a
neighboring village
[Music]
residents of ha Rosanna Gris that John
Blackie is one of a kind under
replacable got to come up with somebody
soon they'll soon be time to hang up my
laptop to hang it up and let somebody
else take on haven't found anybody yet
but I'm living in hope an optimist which
the people of [ __ ] appreciate
[Music]
[Applause]